it's time for another challenge Charlie
on today's agenda we have baby food as a
matter of fact I actually used to eat
baby food all the time when I was a baby
get off the video honey baby food
without being the first thing on the
agenda is mashed banana side note are
you all jealous of my ducky Fork
there's nothing too bad about this I
mean it does taste like banana but I
would prefer my banana to have some kind
of substance really mushy banana gets
two stars pureed Peas
badly pureed by myself I should say this
is a lot better because my bib this is a
lot better mainly because it's not
really baby food at all and because I
did these so badly I can just they just
taste like peas no pureed peas which
isn't really pureed Peas at all
gets four stars my mom got me some baby
rice no idea what the difference between
this and normal Rice's and she got me
some follow-on milk for above six months
which I guess is what I am but she
specifically said that I should put
these two things together and eat them
I've discovered the difference between
normal rice and baby rice um that is not
rice add a bit of special milk ooh this
is in no way when I was expecting this
is definitely the haha you know what
this was a lot of fun but I'm gonna have
to get rid of it because it's just too
small now let's eat some baby rice it
tastes like nothing let's have a second
try there is a tiny hint of some rice
essence but it's very very hidden baby
rice gets one star next up we have
Farley's rusks with reduced sugar which
is apparently what I used to eat now the
thing about Farley's rusks is that
although they're designed for babies
they are eaten by quite a lot of non
babies my mum's ex-boyfriend for example
used to eat these all the time first off
I have to try this with the formula milk
by crushing it into a bowl like so add
some formula milk god this stuff is
weird and now we mix it up into a fine
paste gonna need a spoon for this one
the thing I hate about baby food so far
is its consistency so I guess the one
thing you can commend it on is its
consistency and having a bad consistency
that's not bad at all what I like that I
want to finish this off okay that was
four stars for Farley's rusks and milk
four stars and follies rusks on there Oh
five stars if you ever find yourself in
the baby aisle go for some Farley's rots
oh my god and now we reach the baby food
that I have been dreading the most the
jarred baby food baby berry yogurt it
tastes kind of like berry yogurt but it
has that baby food consistency that we
all know and it's not nice yeah three
stars apple and pear there seems to be a
weird aftertaste that comes with baby
food I'll try a little bit and then
it'll be like mmm yeah hmm but this is
still better than the baby berry yogurt
so I'm going to give it four stars
tender carrots and potatoes oh that is
really not good that is a one star by
far the worst so far but I have
successfully saved the worst to last
this is called Grandpa's Sunday lunch
from what I can see it contains carrots
and potatoes which is what I just ate it
also contains peas and chicken I really
do not want to eat this so let's do it
shall we that seems logical okay we'll
go into this with an open mind oh I
didn't work ah I'm sorry grandpa but
your Sunday lunch isn't getting any
stars at all and there we have it
baby food by Charlie McDonnell you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool